ずンちゃっちゃずんちゃちゃ～
..231
4234（2回目）
ぁ..
4..5000か235
まさき（でへへへへへへへへ～～～～、す～ず～ちゃ～ん）
っぁあ。。
あ..
まさき、飲み物取ってもらっていい？
ああ、いいよ
心の声（ｯﾁ
心の声（めんどくせぇなぁ...
心の声（ぶちころすぞ
まさき...
今なんて言った？
え？いいよって言ったよ？
心の声（ちゃんと聞いとけや！ﾁｯ！使えねぇ
！？
なんだ！？これ...
まさき..
今日も可愛いよ
え？ｗ
やめてよ、はじめさぁ～ん
心の声（あたりめェだろ？
心の声（何常識聞いてんだよこのアホが！
心の声（ﾁｯ
ｗｗ..（失笑）
心の声（っは！？...俺
心の声（..俺、人の心を読み取れるようになってる！
心の声（これは.....
心の声（...使える！
ククク..ｗ
あっはっははははは！
心の声（遂にこいつ、気が狂ったか？
心の声（まあ、知ってはいたが...
おい、まさき
じゃ～んけんしようぜェ！
いいよ。　心の声（めんどくせぇなぁ
心の声（辛いわ
心の声（ひとまず俺は今の能力を把握する必要がある。
心の声（まずは手始めに瞬間的に相手の思考を読み取る練習をしなければ...！
心の声（少しずつこの能力をモノにしていこう...　そして、目指すは世界征服だ。
いくよ～　心の声（さぁこいッ！
OK~
心の声（うぜぇ..
最初はグー、じゃんけん...
心の声（ﾋｬｯﾊｰｗお前がいつもグーを出すのはお見通しだぜ！
心の声（パーでてめぇを焼きころｓ..くらえー
心の声（読めたッ！
やったあああ！ｗ　心の声（ざまぁ見やがれ－
心の声（今の..なんだ？！
心の声（はじめさんの声とは別に、何か聞こえた！
心の声（な！？なんだと？
え？
え？？
はじめさん？？？
心の声（あれ？気のせいか...
心の声（フッｗ　そう..何も考えなければ、おめぇにこの能力を気づかれることはない！
聞こえてるよ、はじめさん
心の声（あっ....
え..なんのこと？
心の声（あぶねぇ..バレるところだった...
心の声（..全部聞こえてるっつうの！
心の声（まさか..！まさきもこの能力を使えるのか？
心の声（よくわかんねぇけど、多分...
心の声（そうか..実は俺もさっき使えるようになったが...　　まさかお前も使えるようになるとは...
心の声（残念だ
聞こえてるよ
心の声（そうだ！心の声が読み取られるんだった...
心の声（それにしても残念だorz
聞こえてるよ！
心の声（はじめさん、どうするのこれ？
心の声（わからない..が！
心の声（俺はこの能力を使ってしたいことがあるんだ
心の声（したいこと？
心の声（ああ！
心の声（えｒいことにも使ってみたいが
心の声（俺は...！世界征服をしたい！
心の声（トイレ行きたいなぁ；
心の声（なるほど！
心の声（...多分無理だな、このあほには（確信）
心の声（聞こえてるぞ！
心の声（俺は本気だ！
心の声（俺たち２人がこの能力を駆使すれば、必ずこの世界の頂点をとることができる気がするんだ
心の声（この人...マジだ...
心の声（本気で世界征服をしようとしている..
それなら俺も協力するよ！
心の声（そして最後はまさきもころｓ！＾＾
聞こえとるわ！( ‘д‘⊂彡☆))Д´) ﾊﾟｰﾝ